hey I'm Darrin a and I play Courtney on
high school musical musical a series on
Disney Plus and I will be making a
gingerbread house and answering some
questions so let's see how this works
cuz I can't cook
[Music]
fun fact I've never made a gingerbread
house my game plan right now is kind of
like a Picasso the more messy it is the
more unique it is you see this right
here this is worth millions I'm not a
good cook but that doesn't mean I don't
want to learn i watch tasty videos all
the time to get my recipes when I follow
something I'm good but free-handed my
go-to recipe ravioli but not like the
good like ooh ravioli like the
microwavable time so what's happening is
the ice thing is kind of doing its own
thing and I'm allowing it because I want
it to be itself and to be free
we have this Lane here in LA Candy Cane
Lane all these houses just light up and
I've been going since I was like really
young and I just love driving and
listening to music and see all the
houses lit up and all the kids drinking
hot chocolate now I kind of just go with
my mom and we kind of just like
reminisce I loved it so much when I
think of gingerbread house I think of
the story Hansel and Gretel I see them
in the woods you know and that's why I'm
adding trees the trees are falling
because life is not perfect if it falls
when no one's around do gummy bear trees
make a sound
we don't know I had a fear of dolls
still do Chucky did not help and one of
my mom's friends decided to give me a
life-sized doll that looked like me and
was taller than me and my mom was like
let's keep her in your room and I was
like we are not keeping that possessed
thing in my room I wonder where she at
right now hey dolly says I know you
watching this
I was such a big fan of High School
Musical like I was obsessed I knew all
the choreography I still know all the
choreography some I know all the songs
from one two and three I do have the
video game I have the puzzle
I have everything the bedsheets Monique
Coleman was my homegirl Vanessa Hudgens
was my I mean like literally I was like
all of them are my best friends and they
don't even know it yet but they're gonna
be when I found out I was gonna be in
the show
I was started crying I was like oh my
gosh like series my character was only
supposed to be in one episode and then
they were like we want you to be a
series regular and I was like scream it
is coming back for season two we don't
know the show yet I just rubbed my hands
all up on these Eminem's I'm so sorry
for all those that are watching my hands
are clean
pretzel and the Chocolate I didn't think
it was gonna stick but it did and I
appreciate that right now I don't know
the way and I don't even know what's
happening next but I'm down for the ride
[Music]
so working with the rest of the cast is
so much fun we're so different that it
just works everyone in the show is
literally so talented and I just I see
all of them just like going on and being
superstars amazing I love you guys
my favorite song to perform would be
born to be braised soon as that song
came on I was like
stream it now oh plane Courtney was so
much fun she's like so bold and I just
really I really appreciate her
uniqueness I would really want to be her
friend hopefully she wouldn't be my
friend Courtney oh wait I got so like
black mirror like Courtney yes wow this
is what my brain looks like right now
when I saw Monique Coleman on High
School Musical I got so much inspiration
like I was like if she can do it I can
do it too and like oh my gosh gummy
bears stick I really hope that I can do
that
like be able to inspire girls as well
that would be really cool
my advice for aspiring actors and
actresses out there I would say just
keep believing in yourself and just know
that there's only one use you're gonna
be like oh she's better she's this he's
that but no you're perfect the way you
are and what you bring to the table is
important because whatever you're gonna
bring that's the only person that's
gonna bring it okay we're gonna put
colorful snow because it's Christmas and
this looks so gross so we're gonna put
some snow at the top this is my
gingerbread house and it's changing and
it's falling and it's staining because
we're all working progress so our
imitating life it's new it's fresh how
many people make gingerbread houses like
this I don't know anything thank you
guys so much for watching make sure you
guys tune in to watch highschool musical
the musical the series on disney plus
and until we meet again maybe I'll make
some ice cream handmade or toast I can
make really good toast
[Music]
[Music]